in this video we're going to walk
through how you can invoke predictions
on vertex AI endpoints from alloy DB
using SQL
this is functionality lodb provides so
that users don't have to manually build
a custom integration for machine
learning
here's our project where an alloy DB
cluster has been created and we will be
using the primary instance in this
cluster to invoke predictions
first we need to Grant this alloy DB
cluster permissions to access vertex AI
to Grant those permissions we need the
project number to find it navigate to
the project dashboard and project number
should be listed under project info
we're using a separate project for our
vertex AI endpoints as you can see we
have a fraud detection endpoint deployed
here already
instructions to train and deploy this
model will be linked in the description
below
to Grant permissions go to the IAM page
of the same project and click on ADD
paste the principle in the format
mentioned in the documentation and
change the project number to the value
we got from our alloy DB project
choose the vertex AI user role so that
alloy DB clusters in that project can
invoke predictions on vertex Ai and
finally click save
as we can see the principle has been
granted the necessary permissions and
now allodb instances should be able to
access vertex AI endpoints
note in some scenarios users might have
to check the include Google provided
role grants box to view the principle we
just added in this list
now to finally invoke predictions on the
endpoints we need some details navigate
back to the vertex AI endpoints page in
this case we want to invoke predictions
on the fraud detection endpoint click on
the sample request link take note of the
endpoint ID and project ID also note the
region in which this endpoint is
deployed in this case it's us Central 1.
now the final step is to invoke
predictions on this endpoint using SQL
we will connect to the alliedb's primary
instance from a client VM in the alloy
DB project
we are using the PG CLI client which is
a wrapper over psql to connect to the
fraud database
let's create a table fraud detection
data which will contain transactions
over which prediction will be invoked to
determine whether a particular
transaction is fraudulent or not
for demonstration purposes we'll load
data from a CSV file into this table
let's look at some rows in this table
some of our data has been transformed to
protect user identities and sensitive
features that's why we see the data in
this form and columns named as V1 V2 Etc
and some columns have been preserved as
is like time and amount
to invoke predictions we'll be using a
function named ml predict row this
function is provided by the Google
vertex AI extension for Alloy DB to use
it we need to install the extension
first using the create extension command
now that the extension is installed
let's start with a query which runs
predictions on some rows of our fraud
detection data table
for each row ml predict row will be
called with relevant arguments the first
argument of the ml predict row function
is the endpoint and we plugged in
Project ID region and endpoint ID into
this format which we got earlier from
the sample request
the second argument is a Json object
with an instances key containing the
actual data that we want to get the
prediction scores for
we want to get individual prediction
scores for each row which is why it row
to Json here is converting a row in the
table to Json
the response Json object returned by
vertex will contain prediction scores in
the predictions key so here you see
we're extracting data from the
predictions key using this operator
finally we're limiting the number of
rows to 500 just for demonstration
purposes now let's execute our query
the response will take a little time so
we're speeding up a bit here to get to
the good stuff
this is the response returned by the
query we have a Time column that is
directly projected from the table and
fraud score column which contains the
prediction results
class 0 here means the transaction is
non-fraudulent and class 1 means that
the transaction is fraudulent
so for the first row the prediction
score corresponding to class 0 is 0.99
which is significantly higher than the
score corresponding to class 1 meaning
the model is predicted that this
transaction is non-fraudulent however
looking at our second row the score
corresponding to class 0 is only 0.1
which is significantly lower than the
score corresponding to class 1 meaning
the model predicted that this
transaction is fraudulent
this query took around 14 and a half
seconds to execute because we're sending
only one row to each request for vertex
AI as in 500 requests just got sent to
vertex AI to get predictions for the 500
rows
to improve throughput we can send
multiple rows in a single request to
vertex AI our next query will do exactly
that
we're going to use Group by Clause to
batch multiple rows together just to
demonstrate we're going to group on a
random integer ranging from 0 to 4
meaning there can be at most five groups
or batches and since we're invoking
predictions on 500 rows the expected
batch size would be about a hundred
now the data under the instances key
will be a list of Json objects instead
of a single Json object like the
previous query we generate this list
using the Json mag function
finally we also then need to unpack the
aggregated rows into individual rows
unnest and Json array elements functions
are responsible for doing that work now
let's run the query
we roughly see around a 21 times
Improvement even though both the queries
are invoking predictions on the same
sets of rows so just by batching we can
get significant performance improvements
the amount of performance Improvement
will obviously vary from case to Case
and depends on factors like Network
latency batch size number of parallel
workers used by the queries Etc
if you want to see more in-depth demos
coming for lodb hit the Subscribe button
thanks for watching